the 0-1 teams that can least afford to
fall to 0-2 0-2 is a it's a it's it's
not an impossible to dig out of but you
you're a week into the season right
right but yeah you you started on a
sunday
for most of these teams yes by the next
sunday you're all in two that's a
problem right and uh which teams in your
mind which which ones scream out there's
no way they can recover from owen two
well okay let's get some teams off of
this discussion right away i mean okay
the dolphins for one i mean you know i
don't know they're yeah they can't
afford to go oh and two because they
want to be on two well because they're
no good and they have no chance of being
one on one the one in one they got new
england so that's over so let's just end
that conversation you know trying
well i mean the coaches and the players
are not right now but you're right i
understand the overall organizational
philosophy is about setting them up for
the future so okay then they're wiped
out they can't afford it because they're
not good enough to overcome it anyway
the buccaneers i look at them as one
team out there i go 0-2 jameis winston
the perception around that team there's
a lot of young players there's not
necessarily a proven commodity
leadership on that team that way i look
at them going on two and go and you know
see you they might salvage the season to
a degree but the playoffs are out of
question and i think the same with like
the giants and the broncos too i look at
those teams and go they go oh and two
the perception around their team is
gonna start to become a reality oh this
is a rebuilding year or a bridge year or
things like that to where i just look at
those handful of teams and go
it's over if that happens and i'll throw
the redskins in that conversation as
well
well and and i see where you're coming
from you're taking it from i'm just
getting the ones of like they're not
good enough to even overcome it it's
over if they go away too and and and
once you just accept that yeah you know
what we were right everyone was right
this isn't our year but but i'm gonna
flip it around more from the standpoint
of the teams that that are contenders or
at least supposed to be okay and for the
browns this is critical to get this win
at the jets on monday night chris
because after that it's the rams it's at
the ravens it's monday night football at
the 49ers it's the seahawks it's a bye
week so they can't lose then it's at the
patriots and at the broncos in back to
back weeks i mean the schedule does not
soften until week 12 when they play the
dolphins no so
hear you they fall to 0-2
this thing can go sideways very quickly
for the cleveland browns and that's
what's awesome about the monday night
match-up because to flip that over
you know along the context of what
you're talking about i'll go with the
jets right there in that conversation
too because of the same issues too the
schedule i mean if you go the cleveland
schedule we know is the real if you look
at the jet schedule oh at patriots at
eagles cowboys and then patriots again
and at jaguars they lose this week yeah
there's gonna be pressure they're gonna
be they're playing teams the next four
weeks after this that are that are
better than them you know maybe they can
win some of those i don't know but
they're definitely not as good as the
patriots twice the eagles of the cowboys
i know that
hey i want to stay in the afc north as
well because we were talking earlier
about the steelers and how they look so
bad against the patriots now they've got
the seahawks coming to town now they
should the steelers should win this one
but but if they stumble and it's not
unprecedented they haven't been the
juggernaut at home that they used to be
no then they have a trip to san
francisco who knows what happens there
then they have the bengals and the
ravens come to town they go at the
charges i don't know what this deal is
going to be this year after seeing them
look as bad as they did against the
patriots i i am revisiting everything in
the afc north now and maybe the ravens
are the dominant team and maybe the
steelers are going to be right around
500 and i don't know is that good enough
no not in pittsburgh 500 is never good
enough especially in a year where there
was this vibe this kind of quiet
confidence that they were gonna come
together and the sum of the parts was
gonna be greater than whatever that
cliche is yeah i don't know something
like the sum of the parts or the hole or
whatever
the steelers were going to be better
this year that's what i'm trying to say
and and it just it just didn't uh it
didn't even come close to being what we
thought it was going to be week one they
lose this week and there's going to be
some folks in pittsburgh who are you
know looking at the penguins hockey
schedule and counting the days for the
nhl season to begin no doubt well it
just the pressure is going to be you
know enormous it's going to be on mike
tomlin
because there's a group of people out
there that just don't want to see you
know as far as steelers fans that just
don't whatever they don't want to deal
with the tom and era anymore i don't get
that they're going to the blue birds the
people who don't like ben roethlisberger
that's going to continue and then to
what you're saying like okay yeah you
lose now you're owen two and oh you get
uh your grand prizes you get to go out
to the west coast the next week and play
the 49ers in their home opener where you
know that stadium and team's gonna be
juiced up and ready to go so i'm with
you they will be a huge media talking
point next week if they start out 0-2
they're they're going to be under a
microscope uh probably
more than any other team in the nfl
and by the way the hole is greater than
the sum of the sum of the parts yes that
is a saying that goes all the way back
to aristotle right so just so we're
clear you don't want to run rough shot
on that that saying there the whole is
the problem is if you start with the sum
of the parts you really can't finish it
you have to start with the whole the
whole is greater than the sum of the
parts gotcha thank you aristotle thank
you and uh whoever put it whoever put
that on uh online so i could find it
quickly on google all right who else do
you look at at 0-1 and say they can't
afford to go to owen well i i think the
same thing with just a little bit the
chicago bears where i look about it and
just go okay really underwhelming
performance week one on especially on
the offensive side of the ball
you know now you're going everybody we
know as we were there last week and
coach dungey said it on the show many
times in the pre-game before the packers
game
it's everywhere we were last week can
trubisky do it can trubisky do it is our
quarterback good enough can trubisky do
it the kicker the kicker the kicker
trubisky the trick or the truth i mean
that's all you hear if they start out
owen too it's just gonna start to put
that bad perception around the team as
well and especially it's playing vic
fangio and that's just gonna add to it
all we don't have vic fans you anymore
we're not the same and i just think
that's to put trubisky matinee in that
offense under uh much scrutiny if they
go oh and two and don't look sharp again
this week
that is such an intriguing matchup this
week vic fangio defense vic fangio knows
the personnel
in chicago he'd been there and they they
this is a tough spot for the bears and i
agree with you they fall to 2-0 uh
either the vikings of the packers
barring a second straight week two tie
at lambeau field between the vikings and
the packers one of those two is going to
be two-and-oh with a two-game lead over
the packers a week into the season
that's not going to be good for the
defending uh nfc north champions in
chicago so they need they need this one
and uh based upon how the broncos looked
on monday night i don't know maybe they
can get it right i think there's been
this assumption the broncos are going to
be better because they have a coach that
the players believe in right that
doesn't mean the players are actually
good enough and i think we saw that on
monday night right yeah i agree or fit
the scheme yet right i mean that's the
other thing you got to take into account
it takes a little while when you go from
a 4-3 defense to now
oh we're a real 3-4 there's difference
in philosophy as far as the players you
need to make that work and i don't think
the denver broncos have it but mike i i
really you know yes the bears should win
this game and they got to be they got to
be prepared to win like an ugly
defensive battle if that's the case you
know they just got to win games right
now and let their offense find their
footing don't just come out and go oh
i'm matt nagy and the chiefs and i'm
going to come out with plays and we're
going to go freewheeling all you know
know your football team know your
quarterback know where you are is the
state of your franchise if you got to
win a game 16-13 out in denver and
depend on your defense be willing to do
that but don't let your offense screw
the game up just because of pride or you
want your stats to look good when it's
all said and done
there's another team we haven't
discussed chris that i think is very
desperate for a respectable showing if
not a victory yeah prime time sunday
night football at home against the
philadelphia eagles because the falcons
looked awful week one you've got an
owner who has to be
commencing that process of moving his
finger toward the blow everything up
button yes and he's resisted in recent
years and he's trying to stay the course
and he's trying to stay the course but
when you get embarrassed like you were
week one and then you come back to your
stadium that is still fairly new prime
time
the an eagles team that the falcons
hasn't been able to outscore the past
couple of years this is your chance to
change the narrative and they need to
come out and have a good showing and not
not 17 14. yeah the falcons need to come
out and do like a you know a 31 21 type
of a game where their offense is
clicking and clicking and i don't know
they can do it but they need to do it
they fall to oh and two and it's time to
start thinking about who i i think
if there's still a lot of football to be
played yeah but it sets this when you
have an ugly streak early right that
sets the stage for the mindset of the
owner to start thinking about who's my
next coach going to be right it's always
better to lose ugly games consecutively
you know toward the end of the year
because the owner by then has already
kind of made a decision what he's going
to do the next year right you're in that
phase in september and into october
where the owner starts thinking am i
staying with this or am i not staying
with this and for a team that's
struggling by halloween the owners made
the decision as to whether or not
there's going to be a change and right
now based on what we've seen from the
falcons so far
you need those wins or you're going to
have arthur blank come november
beginning to commence that process of
wondering who his next coach and gm are
going to be yeah i i hear you i think
that's pretty accurate mike
you know again put yourself in arthur
blank shoes last year was the disaster
of the falcons and yeah okay it's
injuries and all that
okay and then you know he's looking at a
gun going gosh i got us a new stadium
right he's invested in that okay i've
given julio jones money matt ryan the
money devonte freeman the money grady
jared the money all the guys that the
coaches and the other people the
decision makers in the football part of
the organization all the things they've
wanted he's given them and when the
product doesn't look the way you want it
to as an owner you're right i mean
they're going to be on the hot seat in a
hurry if they don't turn this thing
around and uh certainly was not a good
look last week it was poor on really
like dan quinn said all three phases
they got beaten special teams
defensively and offensively and they got
the big bad eagles coming to town who
didn't play their best game and got a
win and that's always a dangerous team
where oh we won vibes are good
but yet we're focused because we didn't
play our best game and we saw our
mistakes on film and that can be a scary
formula
for any team that has to deal with a
talented team like the eagles coming off
that kind of victory
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports